the david pakman show subreddit now has
nearly 14,000 subscribers this is a
great place for people to talk amongst
themselves about politics to suggest
ideas for the show we have one of the
largest independent progressive media
subreddits and it is increasingly active
with a lot of good stuff and stuff I
don't agree with which is totally fine
one post I noticed this morning is a
post from someone named everybody loves
crayon saying David needs to stop with
the shtick that candidates like Warren
and Bernie aren't far left in the
context of modern American politics they
are maybe they aren't far left when
compared to David's personal views but
they are in modern American politics
David loses credibility with people like
me on the right when he says stuff like
this you can't just compare them to
other countries in Nordic countries
they're not far left so what we're not a
Nordic country or any other non-american
country this is a very typical
right-wing view which is as he says it's
not we're not any non-american country
we are America therefore everything has
to be evaluated solely in the context of
what is normal in America that's a
loser's game and the person says you
know I lose there on the right I lose
credibility with them when I say Bernie
and Warren are not far right I would
lose credit credibility with you for
something else you're you're not the
person that I need to maintain
credibility with you have a very narrow
American centric view merely because you
live in the United States understand
that the world is more than the United
States I'm trying to present a
perspective on this channel now on am I
on my show that tells us just because
you're us-based blinders give you one
impression doesn't mean that when you
expand your horizons you realize the
very different political reality of the
world so that's why I the whole point
here is to say yeah we have a very
skewed view in the United States of what
is considered far left when you look at
any other developed rich country like
ours anywhere in the world they have a
health care system that makes sense they
deal with gun control in a way that
makes more sense
etc so I completely reject what it is
that you're saying here and if I've lost
credibility with you because I'm telling
you the real
that in the United States you have an
Overton Window that is far to the right
of where it should be given what other
countries are doing and have achieved
then I'm sorry I guess I'm not credible
on that basis another post from the
subreddit a very interesting article on
Huffington Post which encourages better
O'Rourke to pick a race that he can win
this is exactly what I have been saying
for a couple of months now Beto O'Rourke
in the first democratic debate imploded
he lost any chance he had to be the
Democratic nominee doesn't mean he's a
bad guy and it certainly doesn't mean
that I wouldn't love to see Beto replace
a senator in Texas he failed to do so
with Ted Cruz in 2018 but maybe he could
do it with John Cornyn in 2020 and I
said it but it must six eight weeks ago
Beto should abandon the presidential
campaign go back to Texas and use his
national recognition to run against John
Cornyn there are now more and more op
eds that are suggesting he do exactly
that I love it he should do it
he's got no shot to win the Democratic
nomination some people I know will write
in and say David he has no shot to
defeat John Cornyn he can get in the way
of John Cornyn in a very significant way
causing Republicans in Texas and
nationally to have to spend a ton of
money to defend that seat it will weaken
Texas for Republicans if Beto simply
does as well as he did against Ted Cruz
and I actually think he could win it
would be a fight but I think that he
could win so really glad that people on
the subreddit are pointing to that join
the David Pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash read it that's our EDD
i.t I think before we know it we're
going to have 15,000 subreddit
subscribers there very exciting stuff